maya rudolph's emmy-winning portrayal of
vice presidential candidate
kamala harris i'm just going to have fun
and see if i can get some viral moments
mama needs a gif i just want to do her
proud
this one good job no pressure oh my god
girth berms
[Music]
it's such an honor to be involved in any
presidential race and i mean geez this
one this one's a real doozy
with maya tim meadows and kenan thompson
it's kind of an snl reunion
in adam sandler's new netflix movie
hubie halloween
and sandler called in a few additional
heavy hitters
from home my kids got to dress up and my
wife got to dress up and i was a buffoon
and the movie was fantastic
your wife looked great in that costume
you did good in that thing yes god bless
her she likes staying in shape i don't
well how has life been for you in the
fam and the pandemic are you dealing
with the homeschooling thing and all
that
yes a lot of zooming and a lot of
complaining daddy's screaming get the
hell back on zoom
adam plays halloween obsessed hubie who
investigates a string of suspicious
activity on halloween night
the movie streams october 7th ladies
young appreciate you being nice to me
of course hubie you get to reunite with
julie bowen on this one
love her she's great julie and adam last
worked together on happy gilmore
24 years ago i remember doing happy
gilmore so clearly and thinking to
myself
wow i'm wearing lingerie and carrying
two pictures of beer i hope my dad
doesn't ever
see this and it turns out it's my dad's
favorite thing i've ever done
though julie was surprised her role
wasn't offered to another
sandler favorite he and drew have such
great
rapport and great chemistry
i like your laugh i like you making me
laugh
so when he came on this one i was like
really
not not drew uh great
i'm lucky that i know you so well i love
you i can't think of
any endeavor i'd ever want to do without
you adam
but adam did get to meet up again with
his leading lady when he stopped by the
drew barrymore show
could we see you and drew do another
movie together anytime
drew wants her she's just got to tell me
and then i'll do it but now she's busy
with that show
i i love that i love her on the show
she's cool
i always open up when i talk to drew
she's gonna do that with the whole world